Нарешті те, про що запекло дискутували ще з літа, сталося.
Бойові танки Leopard 2 таки вирушать в Україну.
Це результат інтенсивних консультацій з нашими союзниками
та міжнародними партнерами, і я хотів би наголосити,
що ми правильно зробили, що не дозволили підганяти себе,
а зосередилися на тісній співпраці у цьому питанні
і будемо продовжувати це робити.
На першому етапі Берлін планує надати роту "Леопардів"
зі складів Бундесверу. Це попередньо 14 танків.
Інші європейські партнери з так званої "танкової" коаліції
також мають передати Києву своїх "Леопардів".
Німеччина дає дозвіл на реекспорт. Це означає, що ще 14 танків
Leopard 2 Україні має передати Польща.
Нідерланди розглядають можливість передачі Україні 18 танків Leopard 2.
Для цього вони готові викупити орендовані у Німеччини
бойові машини. Іспанія, Португалія, Норвегія, Фінляндія
та інші європейські країни також можуть долучитися
до "танкової" коаліції. Крім "Леопардів", Україні пообіцяли
й інші сучасні західні танки. Великобританія надасть
14 бойових танків Challenger 2, Франція - 14 танків Leclerc,
а США, як очікується, щонайменше 30 танків Abrams.
За оцінками експертів, загалом ідеться про понад сотню танків.
Це не та кількість, яку просила Україна.
Їй потрібно було 300 сучасних бойових танків.
Тож кількома десятками можна створити лише локальну перевагу
над російськими військами, щоб підтримати один або два
наступи меншого масштабу. Отже, ця кількість танків
може становити свого роду клин, вістря атаки.
Але це не та кількість, яка рішуче змінила б хід війни.
Окрім навчання, як користуватися цими надзвичайно складними,
дуже сучасними системами, існує кілька логістичних проблем.
Одна з них пов’язана з вагою цих машин.
Танк Leopard більш ніж у півтора рази важчий за будь-які інші танки,
які використовує Україна. Тож це створює проблеми для мостів,
транспортних систем, доріг, особливо ґрунтових.
Тож попереду ще кілька викликів. Проте, зважаючи на досвід,
отриманий з іншими переданими Україні західними системами озброєнь,
і напрочуд ефективну здатність українців швидко вчитися
використовувати їх належним чином, я насправді цілком упевнений,
що ці логістичні проблеми з танками також можна вирішити.
Leopard 2 важить 60 тонн і може вражати цілі
на відстані до 5 кілометрів. При цьому сам він добре захищений
завдяки характерній клиноподібній башті та якості броні.
Крім того, Leopard дуже маневрений і легко керується.
Сучасні оптика, тепловізори, гармати та кулемети забезпечують
високі бойові показники. Танк Leopard вважається одним з найкращих
у своєму роді і є на озброєнні в багатьох інших країнах.
Загалом вироблено понад 3500 танків Leopard 2.
У свою чергу М1 Abrams - це основний танк армії США.
Як і німецький Leopard 2, це один із найсучасніших бойових танків.
На ньому встановлена 120-міліметрова гладкоствольна гармата,
а також три кулемети різного калібру.
Танк оснащений комп'ютерною системою керування вогнем
з лазерним далекоміром та тепловізором.
Він покритий композитною бронею зі сталі, кераміки та кевлару.
Недоліком танків М1 Abrams є те, що вони складні в обслуговуванні,
є надважкими і мають високі витрати палива.
Крім того, він споживає не дизель, а дорожчий авіаційний керосин.
Важкі бойові танки на кшталт "Леопардів" чи "Абрамсів"
можуть мати вирішальне значення для успішного контрнаступу ЗСУ.
Вони дозволять Україні краще реалізовувати воєнну тактику НАТО,
згідно з якою на полі бою взаємодіють одразу кілька видів військ.
Найголовніше, я вважаю, що ці танки мають кращу броню.
Однак ми також повинні мати на увазі те, що ці машини
не бачили багато битв. І тому є змішані відчуття.
Попри дивовижні технічні характеристики, якими вони можуть похвалитися,
в Сирії вони були вразливі до мін і мінометів.
Тому ми не знаємо, які саме танки отримає Україна,
яку саме версію "Леопардів" і наскільки їх можна порівнювати
з тими, що були на озброєнні в Туреччини.
Однак незалежно від того, чи була модернізована броня,
Україна отримає кращий захист екіпажу своїх танків.
За зволікання і нерішучість щодо надання "Леопардів"
канцлера Німеччини Олафа Шольца критикували як опозиція,
так і партнери по коаліції. Після того, як канцлер оголосив ухвалене
щодо "Леопардів" рішення, у Бундестазі лунали не лише оплески,
але й критика.
Я хотів би зазначити, що на шляху до цього рішення було завдано
значної шкоди. Лише кілька днів тому ми були у відкритій суперечці
з урядами країн Балтії, з Фінляндією.
Поляки на своє запитання, чи можуть вони поставити танки,
отримали бюрократичну відповідь замість простого "так".
Це значні політичні збитки, завдані Німеччині.
Хто несе за це відповідальність?
Аргументи Олафа Шольца залишилися незмінними:
рішення можна було ухвалювати лише спільно із союзниками,
зокрема зі США, Німеччина не могла дозволити собі одноосібних кроків
у постачанні важкої зброї. На думку опитаних DW експертів,
Росія не може дати симетричну відповідь на "Леопарди".
Росія в резерві не має сучасних танків, які зараз можна було б
розгорнути на лінії фронту. Росія вже надіслала туди все, що може.
Офіційна Москва говорить про використання бойових танків Т-14
"Армата", хоча насправді "Армата" ще не готова, бойові тести не завершені.
І на цей момент вироблено лише два десятки таких танків.
Мета союзників України - якомога швидше зібрати два танкові
батальйони "Леопардів" для України. Це приблизно 80 панцерників.
Підготовка українських екіпажів має розпочатися вже найближчим часом
у Німеччині. На додаток до навчання, військова допомога також
включатиме логістику, боєприпаси та технічне обслуговування систем.
Рішення Німеччини спонукає також інші держави Європи, на кшталт
Швейцарії, яка досі підкреслювала свій нейтралітет і не давала дозвіл
на реекспорт швейцарського озброєння, також переглянути
свою політику щодо надання зброї Україні.
Після "танкової" дискусії Україна ініціює також дебати
і щодо так званої "авіаційної" коаліції з надання Україні
сучасних літаків - таких як F16.